In Myanmar, Reuters journalists Wa Lone and Kyaw Soe Oo...
...were released from prison after President Win Myint pardoned thousands of inmates.
In the US, Secretary of State Mike Pompeo...
...abruptly canceled a scheduled trip to Germany...
...where he was planning to meet with Chancellor Angela Merkel...
..."due to pressing issues," the State Department said.
In Sri Lanka, acting Chief of Police C. D. Wickramaratne...
...says all those responsible for the deadly Easter attacks have been killed or arrested.
Pope Francis made the first-ever papal visit to North Macedonia,...
...where he is seeking to encourage the country's efforts...
...to integrate into European institutions.
Finally from Italy, a fishing vessel that sank in the Mediterranean Sea in 2015...
...killing hundreds of migrants is being displayed at the Biennale art exhibit in Venice.